A lot of late night hosts out there,
they do it the same way.
They come out and they
tell some monologue jokes.
Okay, and they all do
it just like everybody.
Not this guy, I like to innovate.
Sorry, other hosts, but
that's the way I roll.
I'm Conan the Innovator, a
name that never caught on.
Anyway, I've found a great
way to tell topical jokes
that also adds excitement and sex appeal.
Check this out, in North
Carolina, president Trump
told supporters to vote twice,
once by mail, once in person.
Trump said, it's crucial
that I win both elections.
♪ Conan's lighting up the darkness ♪
♪ Fighting fascists and their lies ♪
♪ All the people will rejoice
when Donald Trump cries ♪
Um, what was that?
What are you talking about?
I'm fighting fascism with my jokes, Andy.
Hey, it's come out that Melania Trump
used her own private email
to conduct official business.
Isn't that shocking?
Melania Trump has official business.
♪ Set-up-punch means devastation ♪
♪ Conan set the world on fire ♪
♪ Humor, pathos, and insight ♪
♪ There's no art form higher ♪
I'm sorry, but I don't think these jokes
deserve this much fanfare.
Well, you're wrong.
This week, Grey's Anatomy will begin
filming it's 17th season, yeah.
The big change is that now
Grey's Anatomy is named
after the cast's hair color.
♪ Conan's really on a roll now ♪
♪ Zinging targets left and right ♪
♪ Going after Hollywood ♪
♪ He's fighting the good fight ♪
Oh, I hope you don't get
canceled for that one.
In a recent speech, the pope urged people
to live a simpler, more austere life.
Yeah, then he took off
his diamond-studded hat
and went back into his palace.
♪ Conan joked about the pope ♪
♪ I don't know if that's okay ♪
♪ But I'll sing most anything
as long as they pay ♪
Okay, your '80s singer's
getting kind of lazy now.
Well, forget that.
He's going to be great.
He's going to really get it with this one.
One more, at a zoo in Thailand,
a visitor was caught
fondling a Tiger's testicles.
Yeah, after hearing about it,
tigers in the wild began
turning themselves in.
♪ Sha na na na na na doo doo ♪
♪ Rocky rock rock sing sing sing ♪
♪ Sorry, wasn't paying attention ♪
♪ Checking my email ♪
How was that, Andy?
Oh, I'm sorry. I was, I
was checking my email.
Oh, okay. Anyway, we got
a terrific show tonight.
Beth Stelling's going to be joining us.
We'll take a break. We'll be right back.
('80s rock music)
(leaf blower whirs)